russe nous échappe c'est à dire que la
circulation se fait porte
quels sont les résultats les gestes
barrière le port du masque notre
capacité à tester en masse et en cas de
doute le fait d'alerter les cas contacts
de mettre à l'abri les cas contacts et
les cas positifs mais également la
poursuite des mesures de gestion depuis
la première vague
je pense à la limitation des grands
rassemblements la fermeture de certains
lieux comme les discothèques les
protocoles sanitaires qui ont été mis en
place dans les entreprises dans les
transports en commun dans les écoles
toutes ces mesures nous ont permis de
faire baisser la contagiosité du virus
si je schématise là où au printemps je
le disais dix malades allaient en minute
trente au groupe mène aujourd'hui d'ipad
vont en contaminer en moyenne 13
au bout d'une semaine mais de fait le
virus
là où le nombre de malades play tous les
trois jours je voulais dit aujourd'hui
on estime qu'il double environ tous les
quinze jours
là aussi c'est nettement mieux mais de
fait le virus circule je l' ai déjà dit
lors d'une précédente conférence de
presse si chacun d'entre nous fait
encore un effort réduit les contacts
sociaux qui l'a s'astreint à porter le
masque à appliquer les gestes barrière
se laver les mains est extrêmement
vigilant dans tous les actes de la vie
du quotidien
alors nous serons en mesure à nouveau de
faire reculer le virus quand le virus
circule ce quelqu'un aujourd'hui dans
notre pays
il va contaminer deux catégories de
public les jeunes les personnes en bonne
santé qui parfois des gens ne se rendent
même pas compte qu'ils ont été
contaminés mais qui parfois vont
présenter des symptômes qui peuvent être
gênants voire extrêmement gênant voire
dans des cas plus rares mais ça arrive
des formes graves avec hospitalisation
je rappelle que dans nos réanimation
c'est le cas ici à paris pour dix
malades en réanimation
trois au moins de 65 ans le deuxième
public cible du virus ce sont les moins
jeunes les personnes dites vulnérables
porteuse de comorbidité
ces personnes là font beaucoup plus
souvent des formes graves qui peuvent
les conduire plus souvent à l'hôpital en
réanimation voire entraîner des décès
plus il ya de malades et plus il y
aurait deux malades
plus il y aurait plus il y aurait deux
cas graves d'hospitalisation de
réanimation de dn1 malade on le sait ça
grave entre une et deux semaines
en général après sa contamination ça
veut dire que quand on parle de chiffres
de nouvelles hospitalisations et bien on
parle là des malades qui ont été
diagnostiqués pour le coronavirus il ya
une à deux semaines
et nous savons que parmi les quinze
mille malades diagnostiqués
aujourd'hui il y en aura au moins 75 à
150 qui iront en réanimation et
presqu'autant hélas qui décideront de
l'infection c'est ce qui nous donne de
la visibilité
si ce qui nous permet de prédire ce qui
risque ce qui va arriver dans les quinze
jours à venir et au delà si nous ne
mettons pas en place des mesures pour
freiner la circulation du virus
ainsi dans les territoires où le virus
circule peu le risque d'avoir un impact
important sur les hôpitaux et maîtrisé
mais hélas ces territoires sont
désormais très peu nombreux dans notre
pays
ailleurs le virus circule suffisamment
vite pour que le nombre de personnes
contaminées augmentent sans toutefois
menacer à court terme nos hôpitaux
ce sont des zones d' alerte au sein
desquelles nous avons augmenté la
semaine dernière ces fameuses mesures de
gestion pour faire basculer ses
territoires du bon côté je pense
notamment à l'interdiction des
rassemblements festifs ou familiaux de
plus de 30 personnes dans les lieux
comme des salles des fêtes
pourquoi cette mesure parce que le
brassage d'un groupe de personnes dans
un même lieu clos suffit à augmenter la
circulation du virus est une des mesures
qui peut suffire parfois dans les
endroits où c'est nécessaire à faire
reculer le virus l'effort de plus qui
peut faire des clics il y a dans les
réanimations parisienne des personnes
qui ont été contaminées lors d'un
mariage des personnes qui portent le
masque dans les transports en commun ou
sur leur lieu de travail mais qui se
sentant rassuré quand elles arrivent
chez elle en invitant des amis ou leur
famille ont enlevé le masque et ont été
ainsi contaminées
ailleurs encore notamment dans les
grandes métropoles certaines grandes
métropoles
là où la population est plus concentré
le virus circule plus facilement
il évolue déjà bien trop vite il touche
toutes les catégories de population
notamment les populations vulnérables et
les plus et les personnes âgées les
conséquences sanitaires sont dans ces
endroits déjà visibles les hôpitaux déjà
chargé avec des soignants qui sont
fatigués mais qui donne tout pour sauver
un maximum de vies et qui attendent de
nous que nous prenons des mesures et des
français qui puissent les respecter pour
préserver les hôpitaux et les malades
il y a dans ces territoires on les
appelle les zones d'alerté renforcée des
hospitalisations déjà nombreuse et des
décès les ehpad ils sont aussi plus
fragiles qu'ailleurs dans ces zones nous
prenons du coup par nécessité des
mesures de gestion plus contraignantes
encore pour freiner plus vite et plus
fort
la circulation virale nous ciblons
précisément les milieux et les
circonstances à risque en interdisant
les grands rassemblements
cette fois ci au dessus de 1000
personnes en interdisant tous les
regroupements de personnes sur la voie
publique
au delà de 10 personnes sauf exception
dans le même esprit vous le savez nous y
fermont des salles de sport et imposant
un couvre-feu dans les bars à 22h
pourquoi parce que ce sont des lieux
clos dans lesquels on est proches les
uns des autres et on ne va pas pouvoir
porter le masque respecter la distance
de sécurité
les études internationales et françaises
montre qu'on a plus de risque de sites
contaminés et quelles que soient les
démarches qui sont entreprises par les
personnes qui tiennent ces lieux et je
laissais très mobilisé et je laissais
parfois en colère de savoir que leur
bâtiment que leurs commerces sont soumis
à des mesures de restriction alors
qu'ils ont fait déjà beaucoup d'efforts
mais c'est un constat c'est un fait
quand on est nombreux dans une pièce
fermée hélas le risque de contamination
il est plus important or tout ce qui
peut réduire la circulation du virus
dans les territoires dans lesquels ils
circulent trop et où la tension
sanitaire est forte
tout ça doit être entrepris et puis
enfin il ya les zones qu'on a appelé les
zones valeur maximale
les zones où le risque de saturation des
hôpitaux et des réanimations est très
élevé là où on a déjà commencé à des
programmes et des soins utiles pour des
malades qui n'ont pas le coc vide des
opérations de chirurgie cancérologique
par exemple pour pouvoir libérer des
places en urgence pour les malades du co
lead là où l'incident c'est à dire la
circulation du virus est telle et
notamment chez les publics vulnérables
qu'on sait que quoi qu'on fasse
la situation ne peut pas s'améliorer
dans les quinze jours à venir et qu' il
y aura plus d'hospitalisations et plus
de réanimation dans ces territoires
toutes les mesures utiles pour protéger
la santé des français doivent être
prises adopté et j'y reviendrai
notamment sur la fermeture totale des
barres nous surveillons ces zones comme
le lait sur le feu
un point de méthodes maintenant j'ai dit
que l'impact sanitaire d'une
contamination
elle se fait elle est mesurable au delà
d'une à deux semaines
nous connaissons donc la situation des
hôpitaux dans quinze jours dans chacun
dans chacun des territoires
ce que nous voulons c'est donc que les
mesures que nous prenons aujourd'hui et
des effets le plus tôt possible mais on
sait que ces effets seront davantage
mesurable à partir de dans quinze jours
il ne faut donc pas vous décourager
si vous voyez que la vie si vous voyez
que la situation sanitaire continue de
se dégrader pendant quelques jours dans
votre territoire
alors que vous faites des efforts vos
efforts ils doivent payer et vos efforts
ils vont payer
d'ailleurs et pour vous en convaincre je
peux vous annoncer qu'on a aussi des
situations territoriales dans lesquels
on commence à constater un frémissement
un début d'embellie sur le plan
sanitaire
certes timide mais ça compte je pense
notamment à bordeaux à nice tout même à
marseille même si je le dis tout de
suite les niveaux de circulation du
virus il reste très élevé trop élevé et
que les risques sanitaires et de
surcharge hospitalières sont encore bien
trop important enfin il faut prendre les
signes d'espoir quand ils viennent c'est
un encouragement en fait à poursuivre
c'est un encouragement à tenir
je voudrais laisser la parole au
professeur arnaud fontanet
épidémiologistes membre éminent du
conseil scientifique qui va vous
présenter en toute transparence
des modélisations de la situation dans
tintin dans certains territoires
ces modèles sont importants parce que
ils tiennent compte de toutes les
caractéristiques que je vous ai présenté
le fait qu'on peut anticiper à 15 jours
ce qui va se passer est qu'on peut aussi
regarder en arrière pour mieux
comprendre et saisir ce qui va se passer
dans un avenir prochain professeur c'est
à vous merci beaucoup monsieur ministre
donc je vais effectivement détaillé avec
vous quelques uns des modèles la façon
avec laquelle nous les construisons et
ce qu'ils nous apprennent sur cette
épidémie
c'est essentiel d'avoir finalement ces
outils sous la main pour essayer
d'anticiper des situations parce que
avec des courbes exponentielle comme
celle que l'on observe dans une
dynamique de transmission d'une maladie
infectieuse les effets peuvent sembler
faible au début et s'accélérer
extrêmement rapidement et ce sont ces
modèles qui nous permettent d'anticiper
donc je vous montre d'abord ici avec à
titre d'exemple la région auvergne
rhône-alpes
comment se construit ses modèles sur la
gauche vous avez le nombre d'admissions
quotidienne à l'hôpital ce sont les
points et l'équipe de simon cauchemez l
institut pasteur qui donc fait de la
modélisation mathématique des maladies
infectieuses utilise ces données
observées les points pour calibrer des
modèles qui leur permettent ensuite de
d'estimer ce fameux nombre de
reproduction que vous connaissez tous
aujourd'hui le nombre de cas secondaires
par personnes affectées qui ensuite
injecté dans le modèle permettent
d'estimer les trajectoires et notamment
l' occupation des lits de réanimation
sur des périodes de quelques semaines
donc ce que vous voyez sur la droite
c'est à partir de l'estimation qui a été
fait sur la gauche
hélas le r est estimé autour de 1,5
nous avons d'abord la trajectoire
principal d'occupation des lits de
réanimation dans la région auvergne
rhône-alpes
si rien ne changeait et c'est le si rien
ne change et qui est important parce que
bien sûr on ne va pas laisser la
situation se détériorerait sous nos yeux
et les différentes actions que monsieur
ministre rappelait juste précédemment
doivent nous permettre d'infléchir des
courbes les simulations qui vous sont
présentés ici
vous voyez pour le nombreux airs qui à
la base est à 1,5 estimé début septembre
si vous arriviez à descendre à 1,4 à 3,2
1,1 ou à l'inversé ils augmentaient à
1,6 soit 1.7 vous donne les trajectoires
que vous observez et c'est extrêmement
important parce que vous voyez à quel
point un changement relativement limitée
du r peut avoir un impact à une échelle
de quelques semaines et c'est la raison
pour laquelle toujours dans
l'anticipation
si on arrive à agir tôt on peut avoir un
impact considérable sur la trajectoire
de l'épidémie et sur l'occupation des
lits de réanimation
donc la diapositive que je vous présente
maintenant c'est toujours la région
auvergne rhône-alpes dans une
trajectoire qui était celle déterminée
par les modélisations de début septembre
sur l'estimation du nombre de
reproduction à 1,47 et vous avez
différents seuils qui apparaissent sur
cette modélisation
alors tout d'abord sur la gauche ce sont
les données observées en bleu et puis
sur la droite ce sont les données telles
qu'elles sont prédite par le modèle les
lignes horizontales que vous voyez sont
différents seuils il ya le plus bas le
seuil de 30% de lits de réanimation
occupés qui est celui qu'on appelle le
seuil d alerte à 60% la ligne d'eau
dessus c'est le seuil d'état d'urgence
sanitaire
si vous avez la ligne plein qui vient
après c'est la capacité totale des lits
de réanimation qui est disponible
aujourd'hui en dans la région auvergne
rhône-alpes et lé 2 616 et la ligne du
dessus ce serait la capacité de lits de
réanimation si on était amené à
réallouer d'autres lits à la réanimation
bien entendu il n'est pas question de
laisser la dynamique la trajectoire que
vous voyez continuer puisque très
rapidement ces seuils seraient atteints
déjà on voit qu'au 1er octobre le seuil
d'alerté à 30 % est atteint et c'est
déjà je le dirai une limite parce que il
ne faut pas oublier d'abord que des
patients qui viennent en réanimation ce
sont des personnes qui souffrent et qui
sont à risque de décès de séquelles
graves que pour les personnels soignants
accueillir des patients supplémentaires
en réanimation est extrêmement dur ils
ont été à juste titre
héros de la première vague de cette
épidémie en mars dernier il ne faut pas
leur imposer à nouveau la difficulté
dans lesquels ils ont dû travailler
pendant plusieurs semaines ils sont
fatigués ils se sont à peine reposer
pendant l'été et tous les personnels
soignants des services de réanimation
doivent être protégés il est d'ailleurs
difficile
au delà des lits de trouver des
personnels qu'ils puissent aussi prendre
en charge les patients chaque patient
demande à nous de personne pour les
prendre en charge
extrêmement élevé donc l'idée c'est
vraiment déjà à 30% de se dire que on
est probablement un seuil qu'on ne
devrait pas vouloir dépasser
sachez également que les lits de
réanimation sont aujourd'hui occupés par
des patients qui souffrent de
pathologies lourdes qui ont dû différer
des interventions de type chirurgie
cardiaque neurochirurgie chirurgie pour
des cancers parce que les lits étaient
occupés par des patients atteints par
l'aco vide dans les mois qui viennent de
s'écouler et que c'est dit on en a
besoin aujourd'hui pour ces autres
patients donc une fois de plus même si
vous voyez tous ces seuils tous ces
paliers il n'est pas question de se dire
voilà la marge qui nous restent avant qu
on sature complètement un seuil de 30%
et déjà un seuil qui devrait être comme
il est indiqué un seuil d alerte
maximale
donc vous avez ici une trajectoire pour
la région auvergne rhône-alpes qui vous
indique effectivement à partir du 1er
octobre le seuil de 30% a été atteint je
vais vous montrer d'autres régions la
région provence alpes côte d'azur où le
cac était la première pour laquelle ce
seuil d alerte maximale a été atteinte
le 25 septembre et qui donc amené une
certaine inquiétude
comme vous le voyez ici on observe et
monsieur le ministre il faisait
référence un léger tassement du nombre
d'objets de spitz alisation comparé à ce
que la modélisation prédit c'est
peut-être ce frémissement qui nous
laissent entendre qu'ils aient légère
amélioration mais attention on est sur
des sur la durée il faut que cela se
confirme au moins pendant plus de 15
jours pour que l'on soit rassuré la
région hôte france que je vous présente
ici est une région qui nous inquiète
aujourd'hui vous voyez que le nombre de
reproduction tel qu'il est estimé début
septembre est élevé à 1,54 vous voyez
aussi que la dynamique ce sont les
barres horizontales bleues
va au dessus de ce qui était prévu à
partir d'une modélisation issus des
chiffres de début septembre qui laisse
entendre que possiblement on est même
sur une phase qui va plus vite que ce
qui est prévu ici et vous voyez que les
seuils d'alerté vont être atteint
rapidement donc certainement la région
de haute france aujourd'hui est une
région il faut agir vite
une fois de plus je vous rappelle les
simulations qu'on vous avait montré sur
la première diapositives
si on n'agit tôt on peut infléchir ses
courbes et avoir un impact considérable
et bien sûr ne pas voir se réaliser
les projections que vous avez là sous
les yeux je terminerai avec la région
ile-de-france où là aussi le nombre de
reproduction estimé début septembre
était élevé à 1,4
là aussi on voit que les observer semble
être au dessus pour la partie où il ya
une juste exposition des données telle
qu'elle était prédite donc attention
peut-être que la dynamique serait même
plus rapide que celle que l'on observe
ici et là aussi je pense qu'il est
urgent d'agir parce que on veut
absolument éviter l'augmentation telles
que celles qu'on verrait ici et déjà
comme je le disais précédemment un seuil
de 30% qui s'appelle alerte maximale
porte bien son nom
je vous remercie merci beaucoup
professeurs ces courses sont importantes
ce sont des modèles ce sont des
prédictions et notre objectif vous et
nous c'est de faire mentir ses courbes
de faire mentir ces modèles et par les
actions que nous menons et que vous
respectez sur les territoires par
l'action de chacun au quotidien par la
tension comporte parfois des situations
qui nous paraissent être des détails
mais qui peuvent freiner la circulation
du virus de faire en sorte que ces
simulations s'interrompent et que nous
puissions retrouver une période
d'accalmie
tout en continuant à vivre avec le virus
vivre avec le virus signifie qu'on doit
continuer à vivre au quotidien en tenant
compte des variations l'épidémie avec je
le disais des périodes d'accalmies nous
en avons connu cet été et avec des
périodes où le virus ne circule plus à
bas bruit mais ils commencent à circuler
plus massivement dans la population des
phases d'aggravation
c'est le cas actuellement nous sommes
dans une phase d'aggravation depuis
plusieurs semaines de la circulation du
virus qui met en tension notre système
de santé
et pour lequel nous devons agir et nous
devons donc redoubler d'efforts dans la
période et prendre des mesures qui
deviennent contraignantes quand
l'ensemble des piliers du tester alerté
protéger des gestes barrières ne suffit
plus à protéger un territoire vous et on
vous a expliqué comment nous prenons les
décisions
le classement des territoires en
fonction de la gravité de l'épidémie
localement sur des indicateurs qui sont
fiables qui sont précis qui sont
renouvelés chaque jour qui sont
transparents et nous avons expliqué
pourquoi nous prenons des mesures de
gestion et pourquoi ils font sens un mot
sur la méthode maintenant pour être
acceptée pour être comprise pour être
respecté il faut évidemment que les
français les comprennent le rôle des
élus locaux est alors majeure
raison pour laquelle nous consultons
nous concertons les élus des territoires
surtout quand les territoires sont en
alerte dans l'immense majorité des cas
d'ailleurs le diagnostic est partagé
avec les élus nous recherchons le
consensus en toute circonstance et en
définitive lorsque des mesures sont à
prendre
c'est l'état qui doit prendre ses
responsabilités et qui doit prendre
toutes les mesures nécessaires pour
assurer la protection des français
pour rappel nous avons pris des mesures
il y a trois semaines à marseille à
bordeaux et en guadeloupe
il y a deux semaines à lyon et à nice la
semaine dernière nous avons passé la
guadeloupe et marseille aix en zone d'
alerte maximale et nous avons passé en
zone d' alerte renforcée
lille toulouse saint-etienne rennes
paris et les départements de la petite
couronne
mais aussi rouen grenoble et montpellier
s'agissant des territoires je vous ai
rappelé il ya quelques minutes la
logique et les principes qui nous guide
je voudrais insister à nouveau sur la
concertation avec les élus locaux au
premier rang desquels les les maires
mais également les adjoints et prise en
métropole en lien avec les préfets si la
concertation je disais n'amène pas une
pleine convergence de vues alors l'état
assume de prendre les décisions qui
s'imposent pour protéger la santé de nos
concitoyens
le premier ministre a reçu hier et
encore ce matin et cet après-midi les
maires des grandes villes les plus
touchées
presque toutes les grandes villes les
plus touchées et dont les tendances
observées ces derniers jours marquent
une évolution préoccupante ces échanges
auxquels j'ai évidemment participé ont
été constructifs vraiment on peut dire
que les élus sont pleinement conscients
de la gravité de la situation et engagé
à prendre leurs responsabilités pour
protéger la population
les maires sont essentielles à la fois
pour accompagner la mise en place de
mesures de réduction des risques mais
aussi pour informer sensibiliser et
contrôler le respect par nos concitoyens
des gestes barrières et des mesures de
gestion dans ce cadre je souhaite
partager maintenant avec vous la
situation de certaines de ces métropoles
je disais cette métropole ont été
classés depuis la semaine dernière en
zone de circulation dit renforcé zone d'
alerte renforcée
l'examen des derniers chiffres
disponibles indique the lady une
amélioration dans au moins deux
métropoles que sont bordeaux et nice
mais également à marseille où un certain
nombre d'indicateurs semble indiquer
qu'on pourrait être sur la bonne voie et
je précise que demain j'aurai une
visioconférence avec l'ensemble des
acteurs locaux de marseille pour faire
un état des lieux avec eux comme je m'y
étais engagé l'homme lors de mon
déplacement
al'inverse dans cinq métropoles
l'évolution des derniers jours reste
très préoccupante avec une dégradation à
la fois des taux d'incidence en
population générale et chez les publics
vulnérables mais aussi en terme de
pression sur les services de réanimation
il s'agit des métropoles de l'île de
lyon de grenoble de toulouse de
saint-etienne le premier ministre et moi
avons déjà échangé avec la plupart des
maires de ces villes ce matin vous allez
avoir des peut-être des diapos voilà
avec un aperçu sur la situation de l'île
alors je vous invite toujours je vous
l'avais déjà dit mais à prendre avec
précaution la dernière partie de la
courbe d'incidence
on a parfois l'impression qu'elle peut
diminuer en réalité ce n'est qu'un
l'effet lié à un retard de traitement
des ders des données des tests des
derniers jours c'est tout à fait normal
il faut en réalité
avant les derniers chiffres donc on voit
qu'à lille l'incident se montrent elles
atteint près de 300 pour cent mille
habitants elle est à 100 65 pour cent
mille habitants chez les personnes âgées
de 65 ans et plus mais le taux
d'admission en réanimation pour les
malades du co lead est en dessous des
30%
il est quand même élevé à 25 % la
suivante sur lyon là même de la même
manière l'incidence continue d'augmenter
deux cent cinquante cinq pour cent mille
habitants cent quarante-six pour cent
mille habitants chez les personnes âgées
de 65 ans et plus la part des patients
qu'aux vide en réanimation à l'échelle
de la région auvergne et rhône alpes
on réfléchit toujours résonne à
l'échelle de la région pour ce qui est
des réanimations vous avez vu est aussi
en dessous des 30% mais elle continue de
monter et nous l'avons dit ce matin aux
élus lyonnais grenoble correspond peu ou
prou à la même situation avec des
indicateurs d'incidence et de
circulation du virus qui sont élevés et
une saturation des réanimations à 26%
donc à l'échelle de la région comme pour
lyon est enfin là n'ont ensuite pour
saint-etienne de la même manière vous
voyez une incidence qui augmente
y compris chez les publics vulnérables
et aussi 26 % d'occupation des
réanimations par les malades du co lead
nous avons indiqué à l'ensemble de ces
mères que si les mesures mises en place
depuis le week-end dernier à lille à
grenoble à lyon et à saint-etienne nous
allons évidemment contacté le maire de
saint-etienne que nous n'avons pas pu
encore voir aujourd'hui mais aussi à
toulouse ne produisent pas suffisamment
d'effets sur la situation épidémique et
en particulier sur les entrées en
réanimation
nous pourrions être conduit la semaine
prochaine à placer ces territoires en
zone d' alerte maximale
nous demandons au maire aux préfets et
aux directeurs généraux des agences
régionales de santé de ces territoires
de poursuivre les échanges sur
l'évolution de la situation et les
mesures qui devraient être prises en
fonction de celles-ci à date
il n'y a pas lieu de basculer ces
métropoles en zone d' alerte maximale
mais vous l'avez compris si la situation
sanitaire devait se dégrader
eh bien nous serions amenés en
concertation avec les élus ont décidé la
bascule la situation de la métropole
parisienne maintenant où là aussi vous
voyez qu'il ya une dégradation qui
cette accéléré sur paris et la petite
couronne depuis hier en effet dans les
dernières 24 heures paris a franchi les
trois seuils qui peuvent correspondre à
la zone dite d' alerte maximale
le taux d'incidence en population
générale a dépassé les 250 cas pour
100000 puisqu'il est à 263 l'incidence
les publics fragiles est à 105% 1000 il
a donc dépassé les cent et le taux la
part de patients qu'aux vide en
réanimation selon comprennent paris où
paris et la petite couronne oscille aux
alentours de 30 jusqu'à 35%
ce franchissement des seuils nous
l'observons que depuis quelques heures
nous avons besoin évidemment de le
confirmer dans les tout prochains jours
mais si ça devait se confirmer nous
n'aurions pas d'autre choix que de
placer paris et la petite couronne en
zone d' alerte maximale et ce dès lundi
nous réexaminerons nous réexaminerons
donc les indicateurs dimanche avec la
maire de paris et l'ensemble des élus
concernés
esi la dynamique ne s'est pas infléchi
et que les données sont consolidées je
vous ai dit que à 24 heures les données
peuvent être parfois un peu nous peuvent
nous jouer des tours
et si elles sont confirmées eh bien nous
prendrons ensemble dès lundi les mesures
qui s'imposent et que nous devrons en
tout état de cause d'ores et déjà
anticipé cette décision vaut pour paris
pour les départements de la petite
couronne
même si à l'heure où je vous parle les
départements de la petite couronne ont
un taux d'incidence pour les personnes
âgées qui dépasse 100 mais un taux
d'incidence en population générale qui
est en dessous de 250
nous assumons de prendre une décision
qui intègre paris et les départements de
la petite couronne comme d'ailleurs nous
l'avons fait pour marseille et aix en
provence
car les mouvements de populations vous
l'imaginez entre paris et ses
départements sont telles que l'évolution
en petite couronne suit depuis le début
de l'épidémie
avec quelques jours de décalage
seulement l'évolution constatée à paris
chaque jour des centaines de milliers
d'habitants des hauts-de-seine de
seine-saint-denis du val-de-marne qui
viennent travailler qui viennent étudier
à paris
et des centaines de milliers de
parisiens qui font de même dans ces
départements nous ne pouvons donc pas
dissocier les mesures dans ces
territoires
le passage en zone d' alerte maximale
supposera que les habitants de paris et
de la petite couronne réduisent
temporairement leurs interactions
sociales de manière drastique en tout
cas plus importantes que ce qu'il font
d'ores et déjà plus de fêtes de famille
plus de soirées fermeture totale des
barres chacun comprend que dans une fête
dans un bar la probabilité qu'on soit
debout conçoit proches les uns des
autres qu'on ne porte pas de masque est
forte et que donc le risque de
contamination l'est aussi c'est ce que
disent encore une fois les études aussi
bien française qu internationale c'est
ce que nous observons semaine après
semaine en france et dans le monde
s'agissant des restaurants le premier
ministre a rencontré cette semaine avec
l'ensemble des ministres compétents les
représentants du secteur qui ont fait
part de leur volonté de nous faire
remonter des propositions visant à
renforcer les protocoles sanitaires
applicables dans les restaurants nous
avons par ailleurs avec le premier
ministre beaucoup échangé avec le maire
les maires des métropoles en particulier
la maire de marseille vous savez que
j'étais à marseille en présence d'alain
griset vendredi dernier pour échanger
avec les élus sur ces différentes
mesures à la suite de l'ensemble de ces
échanges
le gouvernement va dans les prochains
jours examiner les propositions qui lui
sont faites c'est normal par les
représentants du secteur de la
restauration et étudier des règles
éventuelle qui pourrait permettre au
restaurant y compris en zone d' alerte
maximale de rester en tout ou partie
ouvert mais avec des règles sanitaires
renforcés pour permettre de limiter au
maximum les risques de contamination ces
nouvelles règles si elle nous semble si
elle nous semble suffisamment robustes
protectrice contrôlable seront alors
soumises au haut conseil de santé
publique elle si elle était validée elle
pourrait alors s'appliquer dans tous les
territoires en zone d' alerte maximale
y compris donc vous l'aurez compris à
aix marseille ou encore la guadeloupe de
même qu'à paris
et dans les parlements dans les
départements de la petite couronne si
les indicateurs confirment d'ici la fin
du week-end que la capitale a bien
dépassé dans la durée ces seuils
je voudrais maintenant vous parlais du
triptyque tester alerté protéger d'abord
pour vous dire que depuis le début de
l'épidémie en france plus de 13 millions
de tests pcr ont été réalisés il s'agit
d'un effort de diagnostic sans précédent
dans l'histoire de notre pays depuis le
mois d'août nous dépassons chaque
semaine le million de tests réalisés par
semaine nous sommes l'un des pays
je les ai déjà dit qu'ils testent le
plus au monde nous nous sommes donnés
pour cela les moyens d'y arriver
en investissant massivement pour nous
équiper en plateforme pcr qui sont des
machines des automates complexe en
sécurisant les approvisionnements
nationaux en réactifs en écouvillon en
enlevant la prescription obligatoire ce
que j'assume en remboursant
intégralement ces tests pour qu'il n'y
ait rien n'a avancé de la part des
français
en élargissant la liste des
professionnels qui peuvent réaliser ces
prélèvements et en mobilisant l'ensemble
des laboratoires capables de participer
à cet effort
c'est grâce à toutes ces actions que de
nombreuses opérations de tests sont
menés d'abord des barnums cédé centre de
test ambulatoire qui ont qui sont mis en
place partout sur le territoire par les
ars et les collectivités mais également
des opérations démultiplier dans
l'ensemble des laboratoires publics et
privés et encore une fois je tire mon
chapeau à toute cette filière de la
biologie qui fait un travail remarquable
des actions spécifiques qui sont
conduits dans les ehpad
mais également dans les aéroports c'est
grâce à cette mobilisation de l'ensemble
des acteurs de terrain que nous arrivons
à tester à détecter les cas positifs
pour pouvoir les mettre à l'abri
et puis chercher les cas contacts il
faut savoir que plus de 60% des cas
positifs détectés sont asymptomatiques
et quand on dit ça c'est légitime
totalement notre stratégie de test grand
public et cette stratégie tester alerté
protéger c'est l'un des piliers
principaux de notre stratégie globale de
lutte contre l'épidémie
mais vous le savez aussi et nous en
avons parlé la semaine dernière la très
forte demande avec la rentrée les
retours de vacances des déplacements
les retours à l'entreprise a créé des
tensions pour accéder à un test et début
septembre des retards dans le rendu des
examens ont été constatés j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire cette situation
n'est clairement pas acceptable c'est
pour cette raison que nous avons avec
les professionnels analyser de manière
précise la situation pour ne pas limiter
limiter à des effets d'annoncé et mis en
oeuvre des actions correctrices qui
commencent à porter leurs fruits
quelques chiffres d'abord vous dire
qu'il n'ya pas de recette miracle c'est
l'organisation qui s'opère dans les
territoires c'est pas depuis paris qu'on
pilote tout ça c'est territoire par
territoire laboratoire par laboratoire
they nécessite un gros travail pour
prioriser les publics prioritaires
quitte à me répéter je vous le rappelle
les personnes prioritaires sont
uniquement les personnes
symptomatique notamment ceux qui ont une
prescription médicale les cas contacts
qui ont reçu des sms de l'assurance
maladie ou une notification sur stop
qu'ovide les professionnels de santé et
les assimiler les aides à domicile qui
interviennent chez les gens une personne
non prioritaire doit accepter d'attendre
quelques jours c'est encore le cas dans
plusieurs territoires du pays pour avoir
accès à un test vous disais on commence
à avoir des résultats intéressants en
matière d'accès aux tests d'abord les
chiffres de la drees nous montre que 75
pour cent soixante quinze pour cent des
tests sont rendus désormais en moins de
48 heures c'est plus que la semaine
dernière
et vous allez voir que sur la deuxième
carte on était encore en jaune avec des
délais on devient vert dans plusieurs
territoires via un site internet que
beaucoup de français connaissent qui
s'appelle qui s'appelle d'octo libre qui
permet de prendre des rendez vous en
ligne pour se faire tester à la moitié
du mois d'août quand il n'est pas
beaucoup de d'embouteillages le délai
était de 4 4 jours parce qu'à des gens
qui prennent des rendez vous à 7 jours
volontairement pour de certains
détestent planifiées notamment les cas
contacts ce délai s'était dégradée il
avait dépassé les 6 jours il est
désormais redescendues au même niveau
qu'à la mi août c'est à dire en moyenne
quatre 4 jours et demi je peux en train
de vous dire du tout qui a pas des
situations où les gens attendent font la
queue ou reçoivent des résultats trop
tard
que je vais vous dire c'est que nous
mettons tout on a tout en oeuvre pour
résoudre les situations qui persiste le
plus vite possible mais que la situation
s'est améliorée
il y à des centres de diagnostic qui ont
été mis en place spécifique je le disais
pour les malades prioritaire en
ile-de-france 15 centres ont été montés
5 supplémentaires vont être montés dans
les prochains jours dix mille tests ont
été réalisés pour les publics
prioritaires la seule semaine dernière
tous les résultats sont rendus dans les
48 heures
cette semaine ce sont vingt mille tests
qui auront été réalisés avec des
résultats qui auront été rendues en
moyenne dans les 36 heures
la situation va donc continuer de
s'améliorer elle s'améliorera d'autant
plus que vous le savez certaines
innovations vont venir compléter notre
arsenal et notre politique de test je
pense bien sûr à l'arrivée des tests
antigénique nous sommes en train de
travailler avec la haute autorité de
santé pour connaître les stratégies
précises de déploiement de 7 est d'ores
et déjà un avis favorable a été rendu
s'agissant des patients symptomatiques
qui permettra de nous appuyer sur les
médecins libéraux sur les pharmaciens
pour pouvoir réaliser des prélèvements
quand le moment sera venu nous avons
reçu hier l'ensemble des acteurs de la
filière santé avec le premier ministre
et nous avons notamment discuter de ces
tests
j'aurai l'occasion de vous présenter
plus en détail comment ça fonctionne et
voyez que cette pour celles d'entre nous
qui ont passé un test de grossesse
notamment c'est un peu le même principe
avec la migration d'un produit d'un
prélèvement qui permet d'afficher si
vous êtes positif au test ou non donc ça
se déploiera progressivement
encore un peu de patience il nous faut
pour ça conforter toutes les stratégies
d'utilisation permettez moi de conclure
mon propos sur les tests en rappelant ce
dépistage ne peut pas permettre à lui
seul de lutter contre la circulation du
virus
il doit impérativement être suivie de
l'isolément de la personne positifs de
la mise à l'abri et de ces cas contacts
pour éviter la propagation d'épidémies
il est crucial que les personnes qui ont
eu des contacts à risque avec une
personne atteinte du virus est
susceptible d'être contaminés s'isole et
réalise le test pour cette raison
l'assurance-maladie remplit un rôle
central qui consiste à identifier et
alerter ces personnes
depuis le 13 mai ce sont plus de plus
d'un million de personnes contacts qui
ont été contactés
alerté par l'assurance maladie les ars
vont aussi un gros travail là dessus
pour près de 400000 personnes qui ont vu
leur diagnostic confirmé mais afin que
les préconisations d'isolement soit
respectée il faut aussi que les
personnes qui travaillent soit en
capacité de justifier vous le savez
auprès de leur employeur leur
impossibilité de travailler en dehors de
leur domicile pour cette raison lorsque
les personnes contacts sont en activité
et ne peuvent pas télétravail et parce
que le télétravail reste possible
évidemment il est même à favoriser elles
peuvent bénéficier d'un arrêt de travail
dérogatoire une prescription d'isolement
servant de justificatifs auprès de leur
employeur et pour faciliter la
prescription de ces arrêts de travail à
compter du 3 octobre c'est à dire après
demain les personnes appelées par
l'assurance maladie en raison de leur
statut de cas contacts à risque pourront
procéder elle-même à une demande
directement en ligne via le site déclare
point ameli.fr ce téléservice qui est
simple d'utilisation permettra de
déterminer les dates de l'arrêt et
garantira qu'aucun jour de carence ne
sera appliquée à la personne concernée
il sera accessible via internet et
depuis un smartphone
et lors de la démonisation
l'assurance-maladie contrôlera que la
personne ayant sollicité l'arrêt de
travail est bien recensés comme qu'à
contacter à risque évidemment
voilà c'est beaucoup d'informations
qu'on voulait avec le professeur
fontanet vous livrer aujourd'hui je
crois que on a besoin d'expliquer la
politique qui est la nôtre notre
stratégie qui est juste qui est la bonne
stratégie à laquelle nous croyons
profondément qui a porté ses fruits dans
notre pays qui doit pouvoir nous éviter
des mesures plus drastiques de lutte
contre la circulation du virus qui a
pour objectif de protéger les français
de protéger nos hôpitaux
comme l'a dit très justement de fontanes
et de protéger des soignants qui ont
déjà énormément donné
nous comptons sur la solidarité nous
savons que les français savent faire
preuve de celui de solidarité et de
courage dans l'épreuve et je vous donne
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour
une prochaine conférence de presse et je
vous annonce également que nous allons
reprendre des points non pas quotidien
mais plus red de madère
information par le biais de mon
directeur général de la santé le
professeur jérôme salomon face à
l'augmentation des hospitalisations avez
vous prévu des dispositifs dans les
hôpitaux pour y faire face oui et
heureusement au printemps dernier
lorsque l'épidémie a commencé à menacer
les hôpitaux
nous avions pris la décision de faire un
plan blanc globale dans tous les
hôpitaux et toutes les cliniques du pays
en annulant la chirurgie programmée pour
libérer des blocs opératoires libéré 17
de réveil pour les transformer en salle
de réanimation
nous sommes capables de le faire
d'ailleurs je croyais au parisien le
directeur général de l'ap-hp qui j'avais
des programmations qui ont concerné des
malades
cette fois ci notre stratégie est de
fonctionner territoire par territoire en
fonction de la situation propre à chaque
territoire et de l'attention sanitaire
pas de déprogrammation général on a le
plus d'outils pour suivre l'évolution du
virus au quotidien et nous souhaitons
préserver les soins qui sont
indispensables pour des malades qui
n'ont pas le co lead augmente alors que
le port du masque est obligatoire depuis
quelques mois parce que je ne fais pas
tout d'ailleurs
vous avez des pays asiatiques qui ont
beaucoup plus l'expérience du port de
masques qui porte le masque dès qu'il ya
une épidémie depuis depuis des années et
qui eux mêmes ont été confrontés à des
vagues épidémiques le masque ne suffit
pas et d'ailleurs le match ne doit pas
gelé déjà dit je le redis être considéré
comme thème d'immunité si on porte un
masque mais qu'on fait pas attention à
ses mains ou si on porte un masque au
travail qu'on l'enlève quand on est chez
soi
eh bien on peut être contaminée et
beaucoup de contamination se font je le
redis en milieu familial ou lors
d'événements festifs chez soi ou dans
les bars ou dans la rue raison pour
laquelle il faut rester vigilant tout le
temps est-ce que les clusters dans les
écoles vous inquiète
non les clusters dans les écoles ne
m'inquiète pas pourquoi d'abord parce
que les enfants vous le savez ne font
pas de forme grave et donc un enfant qui
a le corona virus n'est pas un enfant
qui est en danger les cas rare les cas
de gravité sont exceptionnelles et
touche un certain public d'enfants
ensuite les scientifiques nous disent
sous contrôle du professeur fontanet que
les enfants sont moins contagieux
que les adultes et ensuite les clusters
aujourd'hui qu'on appelle des grappes de
cas ne sont qu'une petite partie une
petite minorité
en réalité des diagnostics qui sont
faits pourquoi est ce qu'on dit qu'il ya
des contaminations à l'école parce que
les clusters sont identifiables
mais la contamination du quotidien ne
l'est pas donc il ne faut pas avoir peur
d'emmener son enfant à l'école et jean
michel blanquer se démène semaine après
semaine pour faire en sorte que les
écoles puissent fonctionner parce qu'il
est fondamental que nos enfants puissent
apprendre et des pays dans lesquels ils
ont fait d'autres choix où les enfants
sont parfois privés d'école depuis le
mois de mars où des pays dans lesquels
les enfants ne vont à l'école qu'un jour
ou deux par semaine
ce n'est pas le choix de la france et
nous le faisons en toute sécurité
sanitaire